hey guys this is andrew from trading
sensors.com
so i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong and right now guys i'm doing
youtube videos
because i want to show you guys what
kind of tools and techniques portrayers
actually using
what i like to use what is efficient
what is working for me
and how to use it so if you want to know
about all the stuff and actually how to
make money on the markets you are in the
right place
so today i want to make an update on
gamestop gme
let's get into it
[Music]
so i do regular updates on all these hot
stocks guys all the stocks that you can
find on my channel
stocks that i mostly take from kathy
wood
just as all the redditors and wall
street batters
and twitter guys are doing and i pick up
those who for me which for me have the
best
reactions are the cleanest are the most
easy to
enter to make some safe and profitable
trades
so gamestop is of course one of them
what we can see guys is that i have so
two trend lines
so the first one is this downtrend so
here it was broken retested we went
higher
i didn't do a video here in october i
didn't have my channel yet
but it was a nice uh situation to play
then we had this short squeeze all right
so guys for those who want to know here
the short interest
was around 100 so when we have 30 40
you know it's a lot but it can go much
higher right now i'm going to show you
guys i think it's around 30 for gamestop
and then the second trendline i had i
need to go on weekly
is this downtrend all right here we have
one but here you have another downtrend
guys all right
and this is actually a level i gave you
guys
when we had this huge breakout at this
480 level it was of course not the right
time to buy it but when it came back to
15 so here it was a bit messy guys you
could have
been stopped if you use my techniques
that's true you know that's why we
you know we need to have a big risky
good ratio because sometimes the trades
are not working
so here let's be honest i think i would
have stopped my position i would have
bought at
50 and probably sold at 40 alright so
i wouldn't get this trade but here
anyway it was
very bullish after we this is what we
call fake breakout because it happens
it happens you know you cannot be always
right it's about
you know probabilities expected gains
this is how we make money on the markets
so here what you guys want to know and
i'm going to give it to you is
targets when you have this kind of
parabolic moves exponential moves
uh you don't have any more support
resistance natural resistance levels
because we are doing all-time highs
if i'm not wrong yes so basically we are
you know all-time highs i mean it was
trending at 480.
would it go higher my answer is yes my
answer is yes because
market is developing in waves and here i
don't have
all my waves formation so
i can feel that something is missing
here all right and this wave is very
strong
it's probably gonna be gonna go higher
than this one
so if it's the case and for me it's
gonna be the case
because here the support level has acted
even if it was a bit
messy it has acted actually quite well
and
i'm pretty sure we're going higher and
the reason behind my real reason is that
i think that we are entering a bubble
guys
so for those who interested to know why
go check my snp and nasdaq bubble videos
that i did uh
last week or two weeks ago so here when
you feel extensions
uh pop up it's here
so you measure the first wave and you
apply it to the bottom of your
second or third wave and this is giving
you guys
some ratios so it's exactly the same
technique
i use on amc guys go check it out to
find my levels and here
my levels are so the 1.618 is the most
common one the
golden number that you can find
everywhere guys everywhere in the nature
you have to build a number and you know
the markets are just
showing the development of the economy
so
it's something that is growing and
everything that is growing is respecting
the golden number
so here the next resistance level is 780
so i think we're going there so is it
the right time to buy
no guys don't buy it here if you are not
long forget it if you are long of course
you don't sell
but if you're not long guys go to clds
go to
skt go to rkt these are the the nice
stocks to buy right now but you can
observe what is happening on jme if
you're not long and see if i am right or
not
i think we're going to 780. so dme
what is the short interest 26 percent
back from 30 so it's slightly lower so
we see that some shorts
cut the position and what do we have on
market bit
shock interest 30
basically short interest is the same but
trust me it's gonna go lower
if we break uh 400 which is the
probably the stop loss level of many
hedge funds so now that's it for me guys
i hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did
please don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show i'll see you guys